hey kids you want to waste some time you
must if you're watching one of my videos
it's time to review some commercials no
no play the column oompa yes the
commercials of the 80s and 90s are back
here to give us that joyfully akward
world of colorfully selling out ticket
Oh enjoy bees bring even the worst ones
can manage to summon a smile to a
nostalgic mind I love them I love them I
love and we're gonna look at them again
today so seeing how one special was
called we'll be right back and another
one was called after these messages this
one I'm gonna entire explanation point
it's here the eating board game got at
last yo you can pretend to healthy t go
home you're safe and sometimes you can
fly really we're including flying in a
board game now you know moving from
square to square doesn't technically
count as flying hmm move two spaces
sometimes you can fly Wow indeed easily
impress a little boy danger sometimes
you can hide to the spaceship the one
that helps get you the most
and the loser has to play the video game
even though I see no reason to make up a
board game on ET this commercial does
manage to capture the magic and
drawn-out boredom of the original ET
board game from Parker Brothers also
sold separately the ET card game oh yeah
I want to see ET in a card game
no he didn't some are simply required oh
great more Finn the world's ugliest pin
cushions oh she's having breakfast oh no
shit you're squeezing her hand you
sadist whoa okay I guess her shock wave
kiss solved everything Punic boom major
stop crying
oh hey mom I just haven't forgot that
about girls toys why would you want a
baby to cry all the time I mean laughing
or giggling okay that I understand but
crying that's a royal pain this is just
what I've wanted to do ever since I was
a little girl
and I guess as is the way of things you
give birth and raise a little girl so
you can immediately prepare her from
childhood to start doing the same thing
hey if I raised a kid who didn't blink
and look like a deflated potato I don't
think I'd win parent of the Year
mountain total born anew your time I
love this commercial because you
literally have no idea what it's
advertising
until they just say it
all you know is that whatever it is it
gives you a great lust for life great
guts
oh great nuts of course because well I
think of appreciating all the miracles
that life has to offer I think of a
cereal that tastes like cardboard and
feels like shitting needles post Grape
Nuts cereal you know when you've got it
good yes clearly this is a woman who has
a good she's on vacation in a log cabin
all by herself no friends no family
sipping the last drop of the most boring
cereal the world has ever created
clearly this is the closest thing to
nuts that she's ever gonna get to touch
what are you doing in Sector 12
comparing our new Hanes waistband the
fruit of the Loom trainee because this
is who you trust with your underwear
right guys a bunch of aging old lesbians
who like to snap your band like it's a
prostitute's bra strap now go through to
the looms bang of course
seriously I'm all for women in the work
world but isn't one guy in there it
feels a little odd here pull it let know
our comfort we've waistband fits better
for one thing it's stronger probably
think I mean how would you like it if
nothing but men were looking at women's
underwear all day hey dumb get over here
feel this bra wow you got a nice broad
come I feel this bra man feeling that
yeah and they're nice in that night oh
yeah good bra good bra yeah I like this
bra really nice bra
shopkins well very nice very soft very
pink
they're pink yeah like flowers yeah
pretty flower like a petunia you know I
think but doing I'd say more like a
buttercup
no more like a d-cup yet man I could
touch this thing for hours hours
plenty hours watch our showers
well I guess if the Hanes fits wear it
Hagen's wins the battle of the bands
that's why we put our name on it
aimes fits better than food of who we
need to get lay here it's new kool-aid
coolers with 20% - wait a minute what's
its new kool-aid coolers with 24 the
chili
this is Jews that's 20% juice what the
hell's our the rest of it that's right
kids 20% juice
it also includes 50% corn syrup 20%
yellow number 5 and 10% God we don't
know what but the FDA was asleep drink
it while it's still unidentifiable it's
just so happy about it - it's a really
we're celebrating that 1/5 of your
product is actually what you say it is
it's a little disturbing it's like
advertising Pepsi
now with 20% soda and 80% rusty nails or
Quaker Oats
now the 20% oh it's an 80% Donald
Rumsfeld though if chicken McNuggets can
make a big deal about having actual
white and meat chicken in there I guess
anything's worth celebrating
ah yes Zack our favorite Lego maniac
a Lego maniac or was it Jack he's
yeah wait a minute is it Jack or Zach
here it's Bell Zach but in this
commercial you definitely hear a Jay his
name is Jackie's new in town
lunch time is when he gets down sack in
fact is that even the same kid my god
it's like they just produce these
children in the same factory they make
child singers this scent is cosmic leap
to Mars he's out there cruising with the
Stars his mind is lost in outer space a
Legoland basket case so obviously there
was a ton of commercials based on this
legendary Lego maniac but it does make
me wonder what this iconic toy God among
children went on to do I mean where do
you think he is right now he's grandma's
house is where he's dazed it's been 10
years since he's been laid and 35 is
well Direk collecting unemployment
checks he's still obsessed with Legos II
it gets much talk in therapy he checks
his list off every day on bullies he
will blow away Zach Zach he's a psycho
maniac Zach Zach he's well we'll still
remember you in this timeless commercial
and the most likely unhealthy obsession
you probably have
Legoland king's castle airport cosmic
fleet Voyager sold separately from Lego
systems has anybody noticed that the
Ghostbuster toys were some of the most
creative toys ever made look at these
these are friggin awesome don't tackle
ah a friendly garbageman you it's Terry
Tripp and as you'd imagine they were
advertised well too but I have to admit
there's one part that just rubs me the
wrong way get a moist ghost funny guy
watching scream am I the only one
disturbed that that's possible anal rape
I mean it's not like we didn't see the
ghost in the movies do something like
this
so I find it very unnerving funny guys
watching scream hey my body would do
that - if Boo Berry was doing me from
all sides and now because I don't know
any better the top 10 out of context
Ghostbuster lines that go with this
commercial there's something you don't
see every day I have seen shit that'll
turn you white you're not sleeping with
are you right
you're scaring the straights he slimed
me I think they're more interested in my
epididymis we get this guy late we won't
have any trouble playing my drippings
with pool you don't want us exposing
ourselves and the number one best out of
context Ghostbuster line to be
associated with this commercial is
that's a big Twinkie plenty of pong
so despite the fact that this scene is a
little risque that Ghostbuster toys were
some of the best toys out there and the
commercials always show it oh this is
what you do with your spare time colored
light yep I think every kid at some
point had a life right I don't know what
it is maybe it's the jingle maybe it's
just a cool idea but everybody remembers
this toy and of course every single kid
in the entire world did the exact same
thing
YUM a dirty pictures with it don't act
like you didn't do this every little kid
did boobies penises and anything else we
thought was naughty made it onto the
light bright screen it was like the kids
version of Craigslist nothing but
perversion as far as the eye could see
my personal favor is when they used it
to spell out words there was always nice
stuff like happy birthday or here Suzie
couldn't use it for more inventive
scenarios
make a face
at night even if we didn't always use it
correctly lite-brite was and always will
be a pretty cool toy and this is a
pretty cool commercial to go along with
it turn on the magic of shining night
light bright from Milton Bradley and a
super golden visit Syria hey it's the
continuing Adventures of sugar bear kids
nowadays may not know this but cereal
commercials back then were actually sort
of like well cereals they were soap
operas with cliffhangers and lingering
storylines half of the commercials
always ended in to be continued and it
was sugar-coated awesomeness but by far
one of the weakest ones has to be with
sugar bear just take a look now we're
turning the tables on you oh that's
sweet we on the double
you got triple trouble we're super bad
news a super golden Chris well gee what
the fuck do you thinks gonna happen
golly could it be like every other
commercial where he just eats the
goddamn cereal and saves the day is that
even a possibility you can solve the
mystery with action-packed sugar bear
flip books look at it they just showed
you what happened they don't give a shit
they know that we know so might as well
just come out and just fly it I mean is
it even worth going through the flip
book to see what happens I mean we all
know the outcomes gonna be go the last
page we all know what it's gonna
Jesus I don't care I still love sugar
bear they look forward to him kicking
some more ass with his laid-back
attitude but Jesus ah pop-tarts
commercials were always the staple of
80s and 90s with its retro fashion and
retro music and of course that confusing
is hell tagline what does that mean how
can something be so hot it's cold or so
cold it's hot it's like saying they're
so great they suck they suck so it's
great I never got it it's like one of
those n riddles you're never supposed to
really figure out what is so hot
it's cool but it's so cool it's hot
pop-tarts a box you can get ready for
something wild when you bite into new
Kellogg's pop guys explosive radiation
god those things are fucking around let
me only took your head off look at that
I think bits of her brain just flew out
there
Lindsey why are you late for class tarts
what tasted better than ever in
producing letterhead
now we're talking Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtle toys always a favorite then these
are your targets the Friends of the
Ninja Turtles you suck your jumbo
what's its name you soccer your jumbo
you sucky your Jimbo it sounds a little
perverted man actually even Leatherhead
sounds a little dirty it sounds like the
name of a gimp from an S&M dungeon now
you can get a pop-up display stand
inside specially marked packages of
turtle pickers great for displaying
Turtles when they're not eating pates
off we just thought we remind you that
the turtles ate pizza as much as I love
the turtle toys and the commercials
there was always one thing that drove me
nuts they never got the same voice for
shredder the voice for shredder in the
commercials was never the same voice as
from the show I mean they didn't even
try I'll take care of them
except for all that sounds nothing like
the original shredder hey while they're
at it why don't they go with this voice
they betrayed me they didn't keep their
promise they tricked me and I don't care
anymore
whoa better watch the old blood
pressures redhead you're just a little
chicken chip chip chip chip - Gigi
how is your sex life great for
displaying Turtles when they're not
eating pizza from playmates
bitch dance club bags do the Barbies
chess
notice how the Barbie in no way involves
bending your arms or legs Oh God even
that was too complicated for the doll to
do look for the dancing toy could you
allow just a little bit more movement
outside of the I'm trying to step on a
bug while I have a headache move Oh
spider got Aviv aspirin where is a
Barbie now the Barbie has club t-shirt
and video with a special appearance by
Paula Abdul now that would be
interesting oh you know you try and I
try so hard honey I just don't think
your Barbie McKeen Cattell
allottee chick she should be because she
should commit suicide she was awful she
is just a god-awful person I think she
should kill this late hour doing
seacrest life speeders oh my god I hated
these things anyone who had these you
got gypped okay so these cars don't run
unless you put these spotlights on them
and there's your problem why would you
want to do that what are these solar
powered cars who thought this up so that
means every time you put the light on it
it moves a centimeter and you have to
have that stupid light on the whole
entire time or it doesn't move and trust
me it's a lot harder than it looks
you get to move a centimeter then
another centimeter and aim for the
goddamn thing a wife Cooper tied on
curves
oh and you got those bridges where it
always got stuck yes why because the
fucking light ones shine through so you
always had to push it with your fucking
toe or something god I hated this toy
take off with the
the black ball shaft future is so hot so
cool
dad you're ripping on pop-tarts who does
that batteries not included not for use
with some cars you put it together here
from Mattel bullshit right transformers
now the grapes are back as classic
pretenders wait what
now wait there people now what now the
robots the dinosaurs - what hey what now
the cars what wait how is this classic I
don't remember this wait why are they
people I don't get that who are they
well then cleaned everything up by that
show-and-tell time I'm having candy that
candy famous teddy bear hi my name is
Teddy Ruxpin can you and I be friends
don't you
Porter why are alphabets fun to eat
because you can eat torture here's a fun
game to play at home count all the
phallic symbols
with
we drink please
for please
don't
don't stop great
this is
probably five just squeezing no new
Pretender transformers are here oh these
things again ok let's see if they
explain today better look there are evil
Decepticon pretenders - mmm finally we
have found a cure for diabetes what I
can't wait for the day I make that
announcement kirti's for over 16 years
I'm sorry you lost me you totally lost
me at that fake-out I don't carry your
promoting if you know what I'm gonna
give five people diabetes right now yeah
it's the critic inject them no just a
little side project I got going Oh God I
might be horrible introducing slim suit
just put it on to take weight off okay
folks get ready for the dumbest thing
you have ever seen could ever think I
could lose weight while watching TV
can't believe we're losing weight just
by talking on the phone no no I can't
in fact I'm going to call lying on that
just put it on to take weight off it's
that easy no kidding
the slim suit can help you lose weight
by doing absolutely nothing when does it
take off like an ounce of weight a week
or something six hours ago I was
absolutely panicked because this dress
was too tight so I knew to wear my
swimsuit and now my dress fits perfectly
really six hours of wearing the slim
suit can make you go down an entire
dress size that's incredible I mean all
you other idiots out there we're trying
to exercise or eat right Oh losers oh
and with amazing slim suit one size fits
all yeah especially for people trying to
lose weight like this guy most one size
will fit most yes everyone can look
great in slim suit
okay now that's definitely alive look at
this girl you know she's got a date to
the prom it's simple the more active you
are the more swimsuit works for you oh
no shit the more you exercise the more
slim suit will help you lose weight yeah
it's pretty subtle that way it's almost
as if you don't need it at all it's the
shape a plan you don't have to hassle
with just put it on to take it off take
it easy or take it to the max
professionals also recommend these magic
beans mixed with a placebo brought to
you by the tooth fairy
when you're in Oz for everyday wear or
every night you can actually wake up
weighing less no harmful pills or
starvation diets and all you had to do
was sacrifice your fucking common sense
because of the incredible demand for
slim suit supplies are limited yeah we
only made 5 of these because we thought
only 5 people would be dumb enough to
buy it you proved us wrong America so
order now to put slim suit on to take
weight off your slim suit comes complete
with the pounds off program at no extra
charge wait wait wait what program you
said all we had to do was sit on our
asses what is there a time scale to
sitting on our asses plumps networks I
lose weight every time I wear it thanks
to some suit I actually lost weight
while sleeping it truly is the work of
an artist perhaps a con artist if you
will well folks I don't think I'm gonna
top this fit of insanity so might as
well just call it quits here thanks for
joining me on my commercial special
every member I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember
Zach Zach he's a psycho maniac Zach Zach
he's a psycho maniac bitch
you
that's a big Twinkie